politique toujours à propos des
municipales justement on va faire un
tour maintenant du côté de toulouse
la gauche espère bien gagner la ville
rose pourtant détenu par la droite
depuis 37 ans envoyés spéciaux alexandre
kara stéphane guillon lionel jospin
françois bayrou dominique baudis en
campagne pour soutenir leurs amis
objectif toulouse 4e ville de france
objet de tous les désirs
dominique baudis est de retour celui qui
dirigea la ville pendant 18 ans est venu
épauler jean luc moudenc le maire
sortant son message qui nous n'est pas
la france
il faut voter locale qu'est ce qu'on
veut comme à venir et que vous allez
soutenir pierre cohen pour en finir avec
le paradoxe toulouse une ville qui vote
à gauche à chaque élection nationale et
ré élire maires de droite depuis 37 ans
le système de gestion de cette ville un
peu en vase clos entre notables s'en
ouvrir à la population est un système
qui arrive à son point du nul
même tonalité pour françois bayrou mais
avec un calcul très différents il
verrait bien son poulain jean luc forget
arbitre du deuxième tour plus tellement
est tellement de péripéties désastreuse
est regrettable dans cette ville pour
que en effet on ait besoin de
renouvellement
justement pour renouveler son image
l'ump jean-luc moudenc a joué
l'ouverture jusqu'au terrain de rugby
m
mr par accident après le départ de
philippe douste-blazy jean luc moudenc
espère confirmer l'exception toulousaine
accusant son adversaire de proposer sans
compter son programme c'est
l'endettement à outrance
il propose par exemple la gratuité des
transports c'est sympathique sauf que ça
représente 60 % d'augmentation de la
taxe d'habitation
réponse du candidat socialiste facile de
faire des économies
quand on manque d'ambition que depuis
quatre ans qu'il est maire eh bien il
s'est refermé sur toulouse et il n'a pas
d'ambition et il a voulu a simplement
asseoir son pouvoir
à gauche il ya également une liste lcr
est celle d'un dissident ps
mais au lendemain du premier tour en
fonction de son score c'est bien le
modem qui pourraient pour quelques jours
détenir les clés de la ville rose